when you make a movie like this that a
lot of families are going to watch
um are you are you sort of prepared for
the amount of emails and calls you're
going to get from people
who are going to thank you and also hate
you for making them do yesterdays
yep we're ready bring it on i understand
that it would be
that it would be a little bit of fear
you know and saying yes to everything
you know but there's still there's still
conditions you know it's not
it's not unconditional but at the same
time you know
uh after all that we've been through
collectively with the pandemic
i think that we've gotten so many no's
especially when it comes down to be
to being in the same physical space with
the people we love with the people we
care most
that i don't know for me right now i've
come to realize if something that if if
the pandemic has taught us
anything is that time and focus are the
most beautiful gifts that you can give
to anyone you love
and when you look because i practiced um
when we were shooting the movie i did my
first yesterday with my family
and when you look at the list in the end
all boils down
to time all they ask you for is time
and i think that that is something that
we've come to realize
through this crazy months of the
pandemic these terrible months
that that time and focus is the most
beautiful thing that you can give to
anyone you love
uh you guys have made a number of
projects and i'm just curious when you
see
in the production schedule your first
few days are going to be eating a ton of
ice cream
are you like oh this is great or oh my
god this is going to be a long shoot
both i think both i think we knew
exactly what we were
getting into and it was exactly what we
thought we loved it
both of us love ice cream edgar is an
amazing ice cream eater
olympic olympic worthy and at the same
time
yes did we get sick of ice cream berry
we did have ice cream made
for us that was half the sugar because
that and
and that was not dairy because um one of
our cast members
didn't love or didn't tolerate dairy and
that i think that made a big difference
for me was a childhood's dream you know
come true in the movie
because i i mean i i'm i'm i'm i'm an
ice cream
you know uh uh craze
and um and and and since i was a kid i
i dream of that actually there was a
commercial in venezuela when it was when
i was a little boy
that it was about another little boy
that would come to a very
you know like elegant adult you know
fancy restaurant and he would be
he will be served tons and tons of ice
cream and that stayed with me so when i
read that on description
when i did it i was very excited i
wouldn't recommend though that amount of
ice cream to anyone
let alone a kid but for me it was great
i mean i i checked it out on my bucket
list
uh jen with there's a roller coaster
scene
and i'm just curious how much is that
fear real and how much is that acting
even as you mentioned it honestly my
heart drops into my stomach
you would think as a producer as
somebody so intimately involved with
every bit of the script with the things
that the kids came up with
that i would not have written something
so terrifying in
but i did and i was
it was almost unusable because i was
cursing and i was yelling
jenna instead of katie over and over
again i practically broke her hand
it was right so when people watch the
movie they should definitely look at
your face
yep uh on that note i gotta go i'm just
gonna say i'm looking forward to adam's
project
and uh uh jungle cruise thank you thank
you so much thank you
next time have a great day